hello rubes welcome to meltdown it's the
live dollop here your host Dave Anthony
and Gary Reynolds
that died fast its Gareth and Vicki
you're on the [ __ ] list supposed to have
friends backstage out here is the battle
that went bad okay Dave Freddy - hi Gary
hi welcome to the dollop this is a
biweekly podcast that just one price one
person sends me a tweet - Mike it's all
over yeah can't you spy wheatley anymore
also I don't know if you've been in
touch to your Twitter they're making a
movie about Hugh glass oh I didn't you
hadn't been told that [ __ ] yeah yes yeah
yeah there is a there is a Hugh glass
movie you guys know this Leonardo
DiCaprio er isn't it there's a trailer
really yeah I'll tweet it at you stop
texting so who's texting is someone
texting buttons people are taking
pictures buttons is text oh we got a
periscope secret he is my boss it's
actually Marc Maron that's basically my
attitude deal out of attendance guys
right up in here and way too casual yeah
yep this ends in bullets oh yeah [ __ ]
Rihanna Manor there you go this kid over
here is going places reanimate new
t-shirt he's [ __ ] way ahead of you
how many people have seen reanimate her
oh that's terrible
that's [ __ ] terrible it's a terrible
ratio we were always this whole show
[ __ ] and your guest is al Madrigal
ah how's it going guys hi oh hey we
share an office we do so I just two days
ago I looked over and I said are you
coming you go I wish I hadn't I said yes
guys I really would I get that well that
I mean that me too
yeah about you I mean if we're all on
the same page are you guys gonna be
dicks about there yeah I know you paid
and you expected to see a show yeah yeah
we'd all rather be home yeah I think we
all would right so [ __ ] go yeah okay
that's fair it's only fair this is
awkward let's face it this podcast is a
chore yeah to listen to to do
everybody's a con sounds like March 24th
1869 what year I didn't listen I'm sorry
March 24th 1860 1869 all right did you
ever listen to an episode that's fine
I'm aware of what you do did you did you
watch The Daily Show before you did that
yeah okay that's cool you know what it
was a time there was a time with the
Daily Show if you had a TiVo early on
that it took over your DVR your TiVo and
became it overwhelmed the memory there
so yeah I took daily show off after a
while the TiVo could they reran it three
times during the day and so you couldn't
find there was a four 3730 like they
were re running it during the next thing
Comedy Central didn't have [ __ ] and so a
I took it off so I didn't watch I
wouldn't say every [ __ ] Ed Helms
piece
and that's right at home suck it we're
coming at you I thought I was asking a
more simple question yeah you should
explain really quick just for saying it
how I met he's one of the first guys I
met in stand-up comedy and in the old
cops comedy club there was a list where
they used to Francis they used to rank
the comedian's
and I remember walking back and we had
never met and I think he was like
looking at the list scowling and just
looked at me like can you believe this
[ __ ] [ __ ] you really balanced out yep
all right but go ahead March 24th 1860
Alford William Lawson was born in London
three weeks after his birth the family
set sail from Theriot Canada that's what
you won't do when you have a newborn
baby get on a boat yeah well those boats
then we're very healthy it was sort of
like a nursery yep yeah letting your
child play with scurvy for the afternoon
got playing at doctor recommended so uh
three years later they settled in
Detroit his father's plan was to open up
quote a one-man factory for the weaving
of rag carpets in order to earn an
honest living
yes that's his dream also not a factory
that's like that's a dude doing the
fix-it guy yeah that's like being like
I'm a one-man party it's like you're not
a factory no you're a guy yeah you're a
man making things there is sad guy
making rugs I'm a factory I'm not crazy
Alphin claimed his father received a
diploma from Oxford University in
electrical engineering invented an early
electrical engine was a Shakespearean
actor and a preacher so he was that's
definitely true I don't see how it can't
be
of his mother Alfred wrote oh god it's
awful when these women get hold of your
a few oh god it's awful when these women
get hold of you the poor devil had to
become a preacher to marry her wait
what's happening right now what is that
that's something he wrote later but his
mom and his dad about his mom's dad know
about his mom and dad he clearly so he
said gay talk [ __ ] about his mom but not
his dad no his dad as a preacher didn't
want to be though had to do it because
of his mom okay you know what this is
[ __ ] it's like he's doing a eighties
comedy act about about marriage yeah
yeah yeah my mother don't respect me the
only records of Alfred Lawson's early
life are from his own writings will find
that Alfred calls Alfred Alfred a lot
it's not a red flag and talks in the
third person about him
Alfred's elementary school teachers said
he was the most unruly pupil that had
ever attended the school and that he
believed there was but he believed he
was there to instruct the teachers
frequently questioning the teachers we
just stopped because when we were in our
shared office and old travel agency up
in LA cañada it's true travel agency you
came to this point and looked at me and
says what do you call it when someone
refers to themselves by their own name
oh yeah I said third person you go no
that's not right it's a common
misconception people think because some
some someone [ __ ] and hold me and I
think they were wrong and I said was it
the bi-weekly guy was our friend Josh
Olsen yeah now that guy's laughing cuz
he's like I know that guy and I just
[ __ ] him through a friend out of the bus
quit talking about him in third person
yeah
Dave Anthony just through juggles and
under the bus okay so are you good yeah
now ever does contact yeah but you just
made me feel like an [ __ ] yeah when I
was sitting there because I immediately
said third-person you said no let's not
write a lot of stupid people think that
oh I'm sorry David Saul eyes
I give him massages that's an
appropriate react I rub his buttocks
with my tongue that's that's not rubbing
okay back to school
Alfred believed he was there to instruct
the teachers frequently questioning the
teachers facts as lies he sounds cool he
sounds like a cool customer
happy-go-lucky easy to teach fun in a
class yeah easy to teach Oh what the
teacher it was probably insane anyway
he's probably right it's so [ __ ]
1800s and it's just all [ __ ] yeah
yeah yeah yeah like a wizard does live
in your heart Alfred enough stop at it's
medical science I don't care if your dad
were invented the one-man factory he's
also a preacher I mean a church
yet the first rug Church life with
classmates was one fistfight after
another he lived by the motto is
breaking right now he sounds like a
[ __ ] [ __ ] it's a [ __ ] dick he
lived by the motto be sure you are right
or don't fight
so he's great then he left school at the
age of twelve what more does he need to
prove there I mean [ __ ] he supported
himself a ferret with various jobs
newsboy shoeshine painting furniture
barrel maker farmhand hotel bellhop
blacksmith's assistant and door-to-door
sewing machine salesman he literally
sounds like a montage a montage that
ends up just surrounded by change yeah
Alfred Elvis
you didn't say vacuum cleaner did you no
sewing machine okay no good but I don't
I'm often here vacuum cleaner in my head
okay
Alfred wrote of Alfred the mother of
Alfred Lawson that's how he writes he
writes his full name right the mother of
Alfred Lawson persuaded him to go to an
industrial school to learn a trade when
he was about thirteen years of age while
there he learned to make coats and
design clothing he completed the tray
school when about 17 years of age
that's what Alfred said but the Detroit
Free Press reported that on April 30th
1882 when he was 14 he was sentenced to
reform school until eighteen years of
age for larceny my true you have no idea
what's happening he got out of reform
school in 1887 alfred started pitching
for a local baseball team that always
ends well and episodes he pitched into a
league team in a game and one with a -
Oh shutout he was then approached by the
league team manager and offered a
contract he pitched around Indiana and
Illinois for the next three years and by
1890 was hired by a minor-league team
called the Wilmington Delaware they were
called the Delaware they just they just
named themselves they said they were
like let's call ourselves the Wilmington
Delaware which is a place but that's
what they fit with what about the Giants
now we're the wilmington where the
Delaware's
no just Delaware okay
the Wilmington every evening newspaper
that's the horrible bad name for a team
bad name for pay extra extra bad at
naming the newspaper reporter Alford's
pitching describing him as a phenomenon
as they as they watched him pitch from
February to March before the season
started on opening day in April April
2nd sorry 500 fans plus the mayor City
Councilmembers and the governor were
there to watch his minor league debut
Wow yeah
alright lost 6 to 2 Sam then he pitched
into 12 to 1 loss to Syracuse on April
19th the 15 of the 0 loss after 3 more
losses he was released by the team why
character issues yep yep you wanted time
that sip right and that just got
anything work on May 6 he signed with
the Boston Beaneaters least they're
trying what should we call ourselves he
was let go after pitching one game he
then pitched two games for Pittsburgh
lost horribly and that was that next he
began managing teams why wait how does
that happen you go to the top can you
teach my team to suck
come on boys have been horrible for like
two weeks he got a bunch of players
together named them the owl Lawson's
American all-stars wait wait but wait
but they are regular happened when does
anyone ever named a team like that we're
the all-stars well what about the
all-star team sorry bro
take and plug it just came straight out
with it they're the all-stars yeah and
he went on a tour of Cuba they lost all
but one of the six games rumors swirled
that the team was frequently drunk in
Cuba and through games when questioned
by reporters Alfred reply no sir I want
to say that my boys made themselves at
all times and any talk you may have
heard about them throwing three games on
purpose is rot Vick rebuttal oddly oddly
specific like you think we throw three
of those games like no I was saying five
wait why did you just throw three what
no I wanted it what do you want that
number crazy you're crazy are you
looking in my head
drugs up my ass what nobody said that
what
Alfred's baseball career continued for
nine more years oh really how baseball
was like just starting so I guess
laughter is not good but was in
something good and then works for like
ten more years just because most actors
I mean sorry all actors it's like when
all actors so he he traveled around
California Spokane Atlanta it did a
world tour in 1893 to England South
Africa Australia and New Zealand
Honolulu he even set up an amateur
amateur baseball clubs in Australia
Haley yeah there's actually newspaper
reports well they were in a stable place
at that time as we know then at 28 years
old Alpha realized that he was falling
into bad shape smoking drinking rich
foods made his Bali and he became
unhappy so who knows everyone around him
felt so he quote shook off the vile
habits and like magic all of his
physical and mental ailments left him
yeah it's crazy when you do stop
drinking every day and smoking
cigarettes you tend to feel better
I don't know what it is but I feel a
little different today I have a drink
nine beers smoked or eight and all that
pig so what to do with this new
knowledge well how I do not but just to
just not be a [ __ ]
how about write a novel great born again
was published in 1904 it was a utopian
fantasy with a complicated plot of boy
and characters that had the same name
that's why the plot was complicated
it's the best way to complicate any
story we're all alfred's I'm a Lawson it
was reviewed as quote one of the worst
works of fiction ever printed something
country's teacher page 28 years old I
have failed at baseball and I have an
alcoholic and I know one name it's time
to write a book one human name I know
Alfred entered the cabin and said hello
Alfred Alfred took out Fred's jacket and
sat down while Alfred massaged Alfred
more Alfred's were coming over later
Alfred thought to himself as Alfred and
his Alfred's wife Alfred finished the
turkey in the oven little Alfred was
sick that winner and I didn't bother
Alfred not that Alfred the other Alfred
from earlier not that one the other one
is this a book is anyone reading this
Alfred thought
so he could write and he had no
experience with planes
well now that's gonna suggest that
planes are about to become a thing he's
into Alfred founded a magazine called
fly in 1908 wait before knowing how to
fly and didn't know how to fly
he had no Aryan aeronautical knowledge
it just went I like I guess planes is a
thing now
it's 1908 what I think flying is the
magazine every article by Alfred and the
foreword by Alfred Glenn Curtis had just
achieved a one-mile flight and the
Wright brothers had made their first
public demonstration so why not start a
magazine I mean that's real early in the
game I'd be like I just happen I gotta
get in on this do you want to see laser
discs the magazine I got a good feeling
about this fly it was very successful
Wow it wasn't what it wasn't it was oh
it was holy [ __ ] he did something right
you were like finally correct you there
because everything up to this point
[ __ ] this shouldn't be happening [ __ ]
not me Anthony would fly took off let's
see in a year it had a circulation of
six thousand a month he then sold the
fly to someone who made an offer moved
to New York and started a magazine
called aircraft
the guy who bought it and have like a
no-compete clause huh okay thank you I
hope your life works out I have fly I'm
also starting fly with what read that
contract [ __ ] within a few months
aircraft was recognized as the leading
authority upon Aeronautics in America
issuing but where does it know anything
right who cares
every kid man succeed okay
he was issuing 14,000 copies a month in
November 1910
Alfred actually coined the term aircraft
he not aircraft yeah
wait well he was in Germany for a minute
he's our cross clock it's like the
aircraft he not only came up with the
term aircraft but he trademarked it that
and airliner he predicted that quote the
flying machine would carry more than 50
people would be able to stay in the air
for five days and be capable crossing
oceans magazines had art the magazine
had articles for the average reader like
why ladies are and should be interested
in ballooning yeah and normal yeah
sorry ladies the planes a little crazy
for you you should be in a basket under
a big bulbous thing get in this helium
basket lady and how to build a gilding
machine
he believed that Factory a one-man yeah
he believed that quote the time will
come when all national boundaries are
wiped out and there's but one people
left in the world
aerial flight will be a big factor in
breaking down these foolish national
barriers which cause men to fight each
other like wild beasts and we'll help
you help to unite them in one big family
airplanes yeah there's a there's a
country boundary here but no more
countries would just be really weird now
it's not aircraft it's aircraft from a
1930 13 article in aircraft quote flying
will develop a superior quality in
mankind as far in advance of the present
man as the present man is in advance of
the ape sorry yeah it's messed up no not
his best stuff we've heard better from
Alfred which is really saying something
by the year 3000 a superior type of man
I mean what a [ __ ] [ __ ] to go to
the Year like Back to the Future was
like head balls to go to 2015 this guy's
like in the year 3000 that's great when
you can hear a faucet turn on effort
joke you know things right good that was
just a guy going a superior type of man
will have begun the altie man a
superhuman who will live in the upper
Stratus of the atmosphere and never come
down to earth at all
an all T man yeah right we died hundred
years away think about a prediction like
that a nice buffer when you die that
nobody can call you on no who can call
him out on it it's an 11 space ulti men
regular men will be earthbound there'll
be no countries and everyone will be
named Alfred all right Alfred learned to
fly in 1913 he became the first airplane
commuter in the country to fly his own
plane flying 35 miles from New Jersey to
Manhattan when the u.s. entered World
War one in 1917 Alfred secured financing
for an aircraft plant in Green Bay
Wisconsin [ __ ] hey did yeah I like the
Green Bay Packers a lot but you're from
you're from up there Milwaukee right
that's up there
why is this so awkward it was like you
just got weird
I did I think people are expecting
something funny instead of like a like a
strange faction and I'm the straight man
I don't understand she took that bait
you're very vocal my dear what did you
yell out Yeah right
no way as Alf
Alfred made two fighter plane prototypes
for the War Department but orders for
the lawson armored battler were rejected
he wrote letters to Congress throughout
1918 urging an immediate increase of a
billion dollars in funding for aviation
that's like all the money back and a
little bit for hot-air balloons for the
118 ladies these are man playing yeah in
his fourth letter to Congress then
before he proposed stationing steamships
with designed flat tops across the
atlantic ocean to fight fly planes over
to Europe claiming it can be operational
in four months that's a good idea that's
not a bad idea it's an area he's talking
about aircraft they gotta be considering
letter number four yeah this one's not
bad you guys the first verse three the
billion dollar - [ __ ] I think we did
some flat [ __ ] out there quote flat [ __ ]
out there the war ended though [ __ ] I
know they'll be more yep
don't you worry Elfie baby Lawson
Aircraft reorganized into Lawson
Airplane Company and the Lawson airline
transportation company the company's
first passenger plane built was the
first built specifically for commercial
passenger travel it had two 400
horsepower engines holding two pilots
and 16 passengers all seated in
upholstery upholstered wicker chairs
luxury right oh nice wicker seat get on
that plane after a long commute oh just
get something quicker in the wicker just
getting something little burn quick yeah
yeah some of this [ __ ] hits the fan that
you won't have to wait around to plan
for anything you'll be gone what if the
airplane doesn't light it's the only
thing he's done that's made sense I get
that it's light it's light but it's
still wicker aluminum's light all right
what do you do next
welcome to Anthony Madrigal material
show down what about feathers one of the
airplane designers Vincent Bernal II
described Alfred as quote perhaps the
craziest man I ever knew he was a he was
a wiry megalomaniac filled with nervous
energy he didn't need alcohol to get
high his his ego kept in floating in the
clouds he was a cross between a crackpot
and a genius that's loaded that is low
yeah I don't know what him hey it's
concerning alfred was trying to
establish landing fields across the
country for coast-to-coast trips he
wanted a hundred planes carrying 26
passengers on 36-hour trips he intended
to build sleepers so that people flying
from New York to California could sleep
like on a train huh beds and nails right
yep something nice sit in two wicker
yeah the arizona republic' published a
photo on october 1 1920 Edgar Croft what
what I say yeah people say first
oh my god you [ __ ] potentials I mean
how are you not all Twitter right now
it's not what he can't block in real
life I didn't know I should have I
should have written first you're right
but I wrote a one
I apologize for ruining the podcast
Edgar Croft a newspaper a reporter is
this is a photo
Edgar Croft what date was this on
October 1st a newspaper reporter was
shaving himself with a straightedge
razor while flying on it Lawson airline
Wow mr. Croft said that he found it much
easier to shave himself on a modern
Lawson airliner travelling 120 miles an
hour than he did shaving himself on a
railroad train moving at 40 miles an
hour what about regular land that's it
why is he even rolling the dice up
anyway it's such a better shave on a
plane because when I was on that
railroad car I think it stretches all
over my face oh it's like testing that
no it's not easy to shave on either hey
have you thought about shaving when you
get there no no of course not
I'm out of my mind time for the balls
I'll only shave my balls in a hot-air
balloon
mr. Crofts catchphrase was time for the
balls Wow what I'm good I actually got a
new computer shower-bath laboratories
and all modern conveniences would be on
the planes in 1919 Alfred scored a post
office contract to deliver mail biplane
contracts for three air mail routes for
six hundred and eighty five thousand
dollars a year were awarded each plane
would carry 1500 pounds of mail per trip
besides the passengers the first chip of
Lausanne Airlines took off on May 8 1921
from the Great Falls tribute with one of
its wings hitting a tree on the take-off
did anybody else see that coming a mile
away I knew those people were dead
second let me mentioned something
positive happened
everyone's dead and [ __ ] dude shaving
is gone with one of its wings hitting a
tree on takeoff of what was to be the
maiden trip the Lawson airliner midnight
liner deluxe valued at $75,000 crashed
fifty feet to the ground Sunday four
passengers including Alfred Lawson
escaped uninjured know what happened to
the mail
don't bury the lede the male was lost
the crash caused his financial backers
to withdraw their support
Lawson Aircraft Company was declared
bankrupt in 1922 he did try to revive it
in 1926 with the idea of a double-decker
airplane to carry more passengers the
first one resurrection yeah the first
one crashes what's gonna be bigger
Samant
he also tried to create a New York to DC
double-decker bus route patent trying to
patent the the double-decker bus but
nothing materialized then Alfred started
writing books not again rather in pitch
the first two volumes of loss and not
lawson lawson anomie lost and Lawson to
me Lawson of me Lawson to me like
astronomy but Lawson to me we're
self-published he turned his attention
to economics philosophy and education
finally lost senem Lawson to me is the
knowledge of life and everything
pertaining thereto
loccent me is based upon life as it is
and not upon a theory of what it ought
to be theory as espoused by so called
wise men and self-styled scholars has no
place in lhasa to me everything must be
provable or reasonable or it is not
Lawson to me lost me treats of things as
they are and not as they pretend it to
be facts not fancies truth not falsity
knowledge not notions it is the
foundation of Lawson Ami how does he
there like 32 - he thought people like
Albert Einstein were full of [ __ ] yeah
finally someone's taken the big dog down
[ __ ] that dude I'm with Al Fred not yet
I mean I'm on your side as I get it
thank you anyway well he was the anti
Alfred in his opinion oh right yeah
there is no greater load I'm still
quoting there is no greater load of
misconception than the unprovable theory
that somewhere somehow and in some shape
there exists a substance called energy
that causes movement no such thing
exists we know he's right now instead of
energy Alfred believed there is a
constant push-pull battle between things
with high density and low density so
materials with high density move towards
the ones with less density this created
suction and pressure for example I'm
excited for this example we are able to
see because our eyes draw light with
suction so everybody also agrees clearly
back on the sauce as a fun month when he
was on ideas gravity was also the pull
of the earth suction Lawson's theory of
suction and pressure was something he
discovered at the age of four when he
was calling his mom a [ __ ] and hitting
teachers
at the age of four when he noticed
blowing on dust push it away while
inhaling it brought it closer the story
there is he was just inhaling dust like
a baby genius yeah Alfred what are you
doing I don't physics it is possible
that Alfred got his ideas an
understanding of physics from his father
who in the three years before outfits
birth spent all his time trying to make
a perpetual motion machine it's always
the dad sometimes the mom but usually a
dad I'll get this okay I'm gonna do it
it's just gonna keep on going forever
watch out Fred get away from the dust
actually get the corners now as far as
the the planet Earth goes the planet is
swimming in ether while the earth is
made of less ether since lathy less
ether is not as dense as ether it
creates suction through a hole at the
North Pole
so earth nutrients go in through the
hole and enter the arteries of the earth
which then distribute the nutrients all
over the planet then they are eventually
shot out of the Earth's butthole the
South Pole
I mean I made that term up but it seems
appropriate
it seems very it is a butthole if it's
at the bottom and stuffs coming out of
it it's technically a pump can't be
[ __ ] on Santa I mean you got a [ __ ]
somewhere right yeah the other hey when
the earth gets food poisoning yeah do
you are you familiar with her I taught
my kids yeah how do refer and respect
the planet I used blood holes for
everything that's actually a book you're
right everything's a butthole and then
there was poverty and economics Alfred
wanted everyone to be given a direct
credit from the government these direct
credits would be used instead of cash as
evidence of ownership of land products
and labor this way everyone would be
able to prosper the poor be fed and
educated and everyone's talents would be
realized
wait why though because he went to
demolition man money because everyone
gets credits instead of money I mean it
is the same thing as money but everybody
gets credits they're just different
they're not based on gold it's just to
get a credit based on nothing it takes a
crazy theory to be like there might be
something to that earth but whole thing
walk me back through that one that one
seemed like it was a little grounded the
idea of direct credits caught on while
it was a sec while it was scornfully
called a movement movement of milk men
which referred to its uniforms the
direct credit society swept the Midwest
it in parades in Detroit in 1933 in
Cleveland in 34 in st. Louis in
Milwaukee well we were followed
Cleveland's libro so not our fault [ __ ]
you on that if you're trying to throw
them don't you dare
thousands in white uniforms with red
sashes and caps with lisanna me on the
visor marched alongside floats with
slogans such as all nations need direct
credits for little children and feeble
old folk is this a parade what is this
and what am i watching over here they
graduate from heaven what's happening
other signs like leader of the world's
greatest economic movement these were
preceded by marching bands playing the
anthems hark to Lawson songs of loss
sauna me and a passenger of truth know
Lawson Pun there huh
the direct credit Society had military
ranks for members each new member would
begin as a corporal and after signing up
50 new members they would advance to
sergeant so l ron Hubbard
hurt that way and was like let's go yeah
they all have to sell soap to their moms
and then you sign up 200 you'd become a
lieutenant 250 captain and so on and so
forth
Lawson claims 75,000 officers in 1934
and a total of a million members by 1936
no dues but donations were paid to
Lawson's Humana
humanity benefactor foundation one
former officer recalled later my family
gave Lawson eight thousand over ten
years that's the reason we don't have a
home should have managed his credits
better what do you want buddy others
cashed in their insurance policy sold
their farms stores and cemetery plots to
contribute why don't we have well a
cemetery plot in that time as we've
learned is not good that's just like
take the bodies and [ __ ] them and eat
their hearts and do whatever the [ __ ]
you want well there are a lot of
vampires yeah yeah
a newspaper was started called the
benefactor the paper once claimed a
circulation of more than six million
which cannot be verified
claiming shits fun the benefactor quote
the people of the US have turned over
their money system to the financiers of
and these tricksters use this money as a
medium to defraud the people by making
them pay tribute for the use of it and
thereby they are enabled to not only
swindle the American worker but it also
enables them to actually make slaves of
the people themselves on account of
indebtedness so it's right yep a real
Fox News vibe about it
they're crazy watch us in 1939 Lawson
published a volume of lisanna me called
the Almighty
so he's stabilizing
the almighty was a little more religious
quote the apeman as God views him is not
a creature of which to feel proud about
every two thousand years a new teacher
with advanced intellectual equipment
appears upon earth to lead the people a
step or two nearer to one god of
everybody previous teachers lacked
knowledge concerning the physical mental
and mechanical laws to establish their
teachings upon us a sound and lasting
base oh dear who could do this job the
name was in his first novel really
they're all so good I don't even
remember the first one let me know who
he picks Alfred yes the guy who claimed
his birth was quote the most momentous
occurrence since the birth of mankind
it's like when you have to write a bio
for yourself it's like super
uncomfortable
BIOS an interesting thing anyway I wish
people can relate to that most people
don't write BIOS you guys you guys know
when you're writing your bio
oh right a bye in the third you got to
be like Gareth Reynolds is from
Milwaukee Wisconsin it'd be like real
sad when you send it like it's someone
else wrote that [ __ ]
well now you can write the most
momentous occurrence since the birth of
mankind may I have the job by 1943
Lawson had penned over 50 volumes of
lisanna me Oh God and then he raised
over $100,000 and bought an abandoned
College on November 30th 1943 the Des
Moines University of Alesana me was
incorporated as a non-profit we're done
get out of here now walk away who said
to do this in Des Moines sounds boring
June 18 1944 it was announced the
university would enroll a limited number
of students applicants must be free from
all mental and moral defects including
such habits as liquor drinking tobacco
smoking gambling dancing and face
painting right face paintings the
Gateway next thing you know you're
dancing I mean
I started with just two stripes morning
and then next thing idea I was blowing
dudes and doing heroin it's straight to
that rose red alone in my place now I'm
an alcoholic and the college would
operate a maternity hospital with the
nursery where newborn infants would be
brought into the world and taught
lisanna me from the day they were born
tell me about destruction now which one
of these poles is the [ __ ] point to
it okay you [ __ ] that's pressure to get
into the university one had to be quote
conversant with lisanna me literature
and pass a rigid examination concerning
its principles a student described
classes you study Lawson's books read
and recite four from the books cool so
that sounds good glad they do in that
place no other books were allowed yeah
well why would they be when the
basketball when the basketball team
brought in a rule book about basketball
no no yeah he had to write the rule book
for basketball
well who's starting Alfred after 30
years of study the degree of knowledge
knowledge Ian would be awarded after 30
years of college you'd get a degree of
knowledge it nothing knowledge a
knowledge Ian knowledge Ian I wish she
made up words they're easier to say
knowledge Ian you are now in ology and
in lotta anime welcome lisanna me
the point is neighbors living nearby
complained about a tall fence that was
built around the university you mean the
prison they also were awoken every
morning by bugle calls and we're
concerned about the young boy boys seen
working on the grounds from sunup to
late in the evening wondering how the
university avoided child labor laws the
fence don't worry we're good over here
let's get any questions
neighbors were also intrigued by the
disappearance of the school's coal smoke
Alfred believed it was healthier to bury
this smoke than to let it escape from
the chimneys we're all thinking what you
guys are all like what are you talking
about cuz you don't know [ __ ] about
lisanna me or Lata nummy the smoke stops
stacks were capped and the smoke
disappeared Alfred did try
unsuccessfully to patent his Lawson's
smoke evaporator when asked how it
worked he chuckled any more questions
everyone wants to know about it but not
until I get it patented in 1943 Lawson
now 74 years old married a 29 year old
woman Miley did something wrong he's
done so much [ __ ] with the way this is
going what do you think it's [ __ ]
what are they gonna talk about not
buying it
wicker on airplane while shaving I'm in
Earth's anus I'm listening that's quite
an age difference by the way they had a
kid all right now I'm back with you guys
hey another janitor scrub the smokeless
chimney he named his son after the
character in his novel yeah it's a
better way to put it all the time he's
named after the main character of my
novel all the characters of my novel my
name everyone's Alfred but the marriage
did not sit well with many of his flock
it was followed by a quote wholesale
exodus of major generals from the
organization oh god what are they gonna
do with that the generals they've
recruited so many there's a spy but
Alfred announced that about 700 generals
asked him to stay as commander in chief
well that story checks out no need to
dig on that one validation enough the
benefactor reported in 1950 that 1,000
cheese were being planned for cities in
the Midwest by the mid-1950s there were
seven outside of the university their
services did not include prayer as
Allison Ian lisanna in law
asla Sounion god acted only through
natural law and did not interfere in
ape-man affairs I mean okay okay I don't
understand it keep going readings and
sermons were taken from lisanna me books
sermons were ended with thus saith
Alfred Lawson so easy to start a
religion it's just crazy you could be a
[ __ ] idiot yeah you just gotta be
like I printed a lot of things
get in here lock that door we bury smoke
these are your generals anybody hear
about Cuba good alright great
we're gonna get along famously hymns
sung included be a note knowledge a lot
knowledge E and be in ology and know God
and where they were think sung as hymns
right yep lisanna me will envelop the
earth and we give thanks for lisanna me
I would just love to hear the one just
one yeah just top to bottom reading from
the book that new guys like what's going
on I want to hear the on April 11th 1951
to Iowa state representatives were
turned away after attempting to visit
the University of lisanna me they got as
far as the hallway before an official
told them to quote write a letter if you
want any information right four of them
if they we don't write back city and
county assessors for years had
encountered difficulty obtaining tax
information one representative described
the institution as Des Moines Iron
Curtain
let's let me put on a postcard right
there I'm down to Des Moines Iron
Curtain Nick come on down March 1952 was
reported that the government was looking
in to the sales of surplus war machine
tools that had been sold to the
University of the sodomy oh [ __ ] I don't
get to with the understanding that they
would be used for educational purposes
the tools have been bought at at cost
for three thousand six hundred ninety
one dollars and sold for more than a
hundred and sixteen thousand dollars
alfred now 82 was given a summons to
appear before a Senate Small Business
Committee he like he's crazy at like 15
at 82 you like sweet God he's got old
person crazy and god-given crazy
he appeared I mean Alfred given crazy
he appeared are at the Senate Committee
on March 22nd and AM fatica Lee denied
that he personally profited from this
sale of the tools he shouted angrily at
the Senate members saying the university
taught lisanna me music theology and
other things so there were no more
questions from the Senate actually I
actually got a degree in other things
from Santa Barbara and then you can get
a really good stuffs degree from UCLA
yeah I majored in other things for 30
years
I'm a general so not a big deal I don't
want to freak everyone out but I'm a
general thirty years studying other
things the Mateen the machine tools he
said were used to teach lisanna me which
he described as quote the knowledge of
life and everything that pertains
thereto the biggest and best machines
the world had ever known Alfred said he
knew some of the tools have been sold
but he said he but he had no idea how
much the school got for them I don't go
into these details I'm thinking great
great philosophical thoughts for the
benefit of mankind meet this [ __ ] you
and your [ __ ] Senate I my brain is
working
can you see hello Alfred said the
school's president is a man named hater
Wow it's ahead of his time whose first
name he was unable to remember he's 82
and pissed and crazy like it's gonna be
awkward as [ __ ]
the president's name is hater I don't
know I'm thinking thoughts Albert
Einstein's an [ __ ] quote I have had
probably two million names flow through
my brain the last 20 years I can't think
of all these little things I've written
50 books already in the past 20 years
and that wears on your memory that is
the best thing to say when you forget
someone's name like I've learned too
many names I have said that I've
actually met you before
sorry bro
at some point you did all you see is
consonants
Alfred's attempts to explain lisanna me
to the senators were confusing so
there's other quotes besides the ones
you read right yeah those are pretty
clear as he left he called the
experience the damnedest thing I've ever
heard in all my life
a senator responded I don't know whether
you're talking about the same thing but
I'm inclined to agree with you it's
crazy when you're on a senator's side
like that guys awesome then an officer
of the university testified that a
hundred and fifty thousand dollar profit
on the machine tools went for university
expenses the IRS revoked the
university's nonprofit status and alfred
lawson was forced to auction his school
to a developer who turned it into a
shopping mall all was over alfred lawson
founder of lisanna me died November 29th
1954 of a heart attack in San Antonio
Texas in a hotel at 85 years old in 1955
the university was being razzed when
construction workers found 300-foot long
tunnels leading from the boiler room
where a fan blew the smoke from the
power plant through the tunnels and up
and events the openings to the outside
were covered with shrubbery he's just
pumping smoke into that's there about
the smoke stacks he just tunneled it
through bushes
nobody couldn't get a patent for it
would you have enough little kids I
working for you you really can
accomplish a tremendous amount
yeah it was just like busywork he's like
dig tunnels dig Tommy dig the humanity
benefactor foundation owned a farm in
Wisconsin where the University of
lisanna me was then relocated again 1956
for students University officers and
caretakers lived on the farm for years
and around a hundred students will hold
a reunion there once a year in 1979 you
are absolutely correct in having that
reaction to this [ __ ] crazy story
because it's super close to us let's all
think about also we started on March
24th 1869 the impact that this guy is
having after he's [ __ ] dead and none
of us are gonna do that
not one person in here is gonna have the
same effect so he might be just batshit
[ __ ] crazy former baseball player who
went on to write a magazine on the
industry he knew nothing about started a
[ __ ] religion but that religion
somehow went on to 19 [ __ ] 79 so I
don't know what we're about to hear but
this is incredible what do you got well
in 1979 nine degrees of knowledge
knowledge Ian were awarded to mostly
people in their 80s and 90s who had been
studying for over 30 years it's
graduation yeah
you don't get a job chickaleta this job
back is terrible
my degree well my specialty is a varus
butt hole
let me finish
oh how it's finished
the Chicago Reader June 18 Gago Raiders
good 1998 it's [ __ ] horrible when the
crazy [ __ ] from the eighteen hundreds
gets this close to us isn't it a sign a
signed banner to cross a fence facing
Interstate 94 about a mile south of the
first exit to Racine Wisconsin that's
read my fireworks that reads University
of lisanna me there are a few signs of
life in the empty fields along the road
but on one farm Merle and Margie Hayden
live in the house Merle directs the
University Marge is 79 and Merle is 78
both began following Lawson when they
were teenagers you know what listen a
lot of you guys you're gonna have
[ __ ] job a job but these people found
something and they hooked into it and
this is a very satisfying life I think
we all know what we need to do
who's really crazy in this store think
about that gang they are not the last
living lisanna mmus the promise easy
how many lisanna miss are there in the
world not enough he answers Morel
conducts monthly mean for guys tonight
hashtag lisanna me and we're gonna bring
this back hashtag we're trending we're
trending I don't know buddy we're doing
it though everybody's saying it um yeah
mark conducts monthly meeting with his
students but there are no resident
students lisanna me is a home study
course now given free of charge
I mean because you just find it online
to earn a degree strive to earn a degree
certifying a graduate as a knowledge Ian
still takes 30 years I can't explain all
the stuff in an afternoon says Merl who
is a knowledge area are those the two
options can you do it in an afternoon
can you do it in 30 years let's go with
that one then but you know if it's like
three minutes a day you're putting in
it's just like the 8 minute abs of your
mind no it comes out of the Earth's
butthole study again
nobody forgot that fact you're like well
I got the one I'll remember the South
Pole is an anus Merl is in all knowledge
n' i've been studying it for more than
50 years myself reported on March 3rd
2015 hold on hold on take it easy take
it easy
it's not what you think just morels did
a Kickstarter a Kickstarter campaign to
make the film last of those the lisanna
mmus following Merrill Hayden the last
crusading member of lisanna me raised
sixteen thousand in 2013 too much a ten
thousand grant from the Wisconsin
Humanities Council will be used for
post-production costs with the film with
the goal of a Film Festival for mayor
later this year that's actually what
we're going when you come out morose
here that would be the best way to do it
by the way we're on a ship and we're in
Des Moines we've been flying there the
whole time
yeah how's everyone enjoying the wicker
I'll put up a trailer for the movie on
Facebook
that's it it's over yeah okay
thank Alfred Jesus forever it's really
doing my head in now you're gonna wake
up tonight in the middle of the night
and be like yeah let's all go to the
ball it'd be great to start doing it
like through the mall now like it's like
the stores like down you ever wonder
what the polls are like those sweaters I
just gonna say what do you ever wonder
what the polls really are come in the
background real quick we you guys thank
you for coming out thank you no magical
for joining us thanks to Garrett Gary
Reynolds Gary I've been Gabe Anthony
Zach was on sound thank you